tools very than sophistication plastic
steel and even electronic I don't little
Dave I don't think you can take a meter
deep as if it on stage it's a real-life
gold rush in Kent on England southeast
coast Berlin artist Michael sale
Stauffer buried 30 gold bars as part of
folks tins triennial art festival
they're worth 16 and a half thousand
dollars the difficult thing that is what
they do with that gold bar do they eat
it and treat it as art do they sell it
do they keep it as an investment and
hope that the price of gold goes up but
the art context it makes it special it's
not just any old gold it has a future
possibly head on the art market which is
more lucrative than the gold market five
pieces of bullion have been dug from the
sand so far new turf emerges with each
low tide tools well they've turned out
not to matter so much so it's not easy
to find these gold bars even with a
metal detector because along with the
goals that may have buried disguise
Washington as soon as I am allowed to
take my suit up and stop stalking
journalist I'll be down there with my
space